Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I am your host, David Flanagan, also known
across Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we are taking a look at a
new tool to help simplify deployments
to Kubernetes.
The tool is called Acorn,
and and tradition to to us today and
giving us more context and insights is Darren
Shepherd,
the chief architect and vendor. Hey, man. How's
it going? Hello.
Good. Good. Excited to be here. Excited to
show off Acorn.
Awesome. Well, thank you for joining us today.
I think I I'm particularly excited for this
one. I'm looking forward to seeing how we
can kind of change the way that Kubernetes
apps are deployed today. We are in a
a very interesting landscape. I don't know if
that's the right way to phrase it. But
I remember speaking to Brian Grant once at
Google, and he said he has a spreadsheet
and has over a thousand tools
to deploy to Kubernetes customers.
That's
a lot my gosh. Yeah. Yeah. A lot
of opinions. So before
we take a look at Acorn, do you
wanna give us a a quick introduction into
who you are and what you're up to?
Yeah. So so, yeah, so I'm Darren Sheppard.
I'm the chief architect at Acorn Labs labs.
So we're a new startup doing Acorn.
Previously,
I was at Rancher,
so I've kinda been in the Kubernetes space
for a while.
Currently, k three s. That's probably the most
popular thing
that I've that I've done.
So, yeah, that's kind of my background. Been
doing k three s for a while. And
and
if you follow me on Twitter, I'm on
Twitter at I Build The Cloud.
I'm I'm pretty well known for just complaining
about everything. Just frustrated and complaining about everything.
And so so yeah.
Yeah. That's that's not a bad thing. Like,
when we get frustrated at software, we get
to bring our opinions and hopefully make the
entire community and ecosystem better
by solving some of those frustrations. Right? And
I I'm hoping that's what Yeah. Is to
some degree that as you take a look
at this landscape of Kubernetes, this can be
better. Yeah.
I mean, that's, like, their basic idea is,
like, it's just try to you know, it's
like I complain a lot, but I also
do write software and try to fix things.
And so the idea with with Acorn is
to try to, you know, make deploying apps
on Kubernetes,
you know, just a simpler experience.
Well, yeah. I mean, you've got that bit
of a legacy behind you now with KCS.
Like, deploying and running a Kubernetes cluster is
cumbersome at best and painful
and
sleep deprived at worst. And that single lane
deploy of KCS
really made everyone's lives a lot simpler and
easier. So, you know,
hopefully, you're bringing that same
kind of frustration solving approach driven development to
Acorn, and hopefully, it's helping everybody as well.
Yeah. Yeah. So, I mean, so, like, when
I announced Acorn, the kind of the the
blog, I I I wrote a blog that
kind of told a little story about with
my son where I
he wanted a Minecraft server.
He wanted me to run Minecraft server. So
I went and I ran a k three
s.
So, you know, it's like I created k
three s. I can go and run it.
It's really simple. And then I started, like,
creating the Minecraft server on there, and and
I just got frustrated with it. I was
just like, this is just way too much
effort. And I went back to Docker Compose,
and I'm just like, there's there's gotta be
a better, you know, a better way to
run applications.
Because, like, for just some simple little side
thing, like running the Minecraft servers, like, this
is just way too much effort.
So I kind of look at it as,
like,
you know,
k three s was my best attempt at
making
running the cluster really easy for just kind
of like a random person or or there's
a lot of, you know, amazing production use
cases for it. But
so this is like, now I wanna move
up the stack and just focus on deployments.
Like, how do you actually make consuming and
using Kubernetes easier?
Awesome.
So
I'm going for a a correction before I
get something really wrong. I think that's thousand
tools. I know it's, it's a hundred. I'm
starting to doubt myself, but I can't remember.
So I'm gonna clarify that later. But just
in case anyone's sitting right here Okay. Ridiculous.
Well, all you have to do yeah. Just
just look at the CNCF
landscape,
and, like, that convinces you of the complexity.
It's like, you know, that thing just the
icons just keep getting smaller and smaller on
there. So
Yeah. More and more things to learn all
the time. But I'm not I'm not gonna
run up with that today.
Alright. Let's talk about,
you know,
kind of
I wanna touch on the inspiration behind Acorn.
Like, I'm assuming your your first Kubernetes application
deployment wasn't with Acorn, of course. So I'm
curious about Oh, no. Of course. Yeah. You
know, what's your
what's your journey there? Did you if you
always just use straight up YAML, have you
played with other tools?
How did we get to where we are
Yeah.
So, I mean, I've so honestly so the
my biggest focus within, like, the Kubernetes world
has actually been helping people deploy clusters. And
so I haven't spent, like, a significant like,
I haven't spent
a significant time, like, myself having to write
and manage deployments on top of Kubernetes because
I've, you know, last five or six years
at at Rancher,
which is all about running clusters, so the
infrastructure ends.
So I haven't you know, my my past
is not so much running applications
specifically.
Because, like, honestly, whenever I got into that
space, I would just get frustrated.
But at Rancher, like, we did our best
to really try to standardize around Helm. We
did a lot of Helm. So I know
Helm, like, through and through every little trick
with it.
Know the guts of that very, very well.
And so we kind of did our best
to try to make
you know, like, how can we manage deployments
with Helm? And so that's kind of one
of the like, just looking at the complexities
of,
creating Helm charts. But the thing that was
interesting when I looked at Helm was it
was like, well, how could I do Helm
better?
And it's like, well, you know, you could
definitely improve, like, the syntax or something. You
know? The the templating is kind of difficult.
But, fundamentally, the the thing with Helm was
that
Kubernetes can do anything, and, therefore, Helm can
do anything because it's designed to just package
anything.
And so that kind of led to this
problem of, like, well, I can't really actually
make Helm better because it has to do
absolutely everything.
So, like, when I started Acorn was like,
well, what if I just focus on application?
Not like I wanna deploy a CNI driver
or, you know, like, the storage system, the
real low level stuff that needs, like, privileges
and, like, you know, low level like, what
if I just focus on applications?
Can I make that better? And so, like,
as I looked at that, it's like, oh,
yeah. This becomes drastically easier if we just
kinda look at the application domain.
And so that's, you know, that's kinda where
Acorn sits. It's like Helm does absolutely everything,
you kinda get the the pros and cons
of that, but Acorn is is focused more
on just the
application deployments.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, this is no surprise
to people who have watched my channel before,
but this is our first conversation. My my
not I don't wanna say hatred of Helm,
but I have a
not a lot of pretty happy things to
say about Helm. And it's not because it's
tool. It's because
every option in a Helm chart now becomes
a point of configuration. And we end up
with this explosion
of interpolation and templating and conditionals and a
huge values Yep. You know, which now needs
a schema, which now have baked the comments.
And I'm just like,
we've went down a very dark path here
and we're we're kinda not doing best practice.
We're not even doing good practice. We're just
retrofitting something.
I'm also not a fan of code template
language either.
I think, you know Me neither. Yeah. Mean
Yeah. Go for it. Yeah. Go ahead. I
mean, I've made the comment before. Like, I
think the only reason why it's popular is
because it's in the SDK. It's like it's
it's just part of Golang itself, so people
are like, oh, I'll just default to that.
I don't have to have another library. But
it is
one of the,
yeah, kind of oddest
I don't know how to say it nice.
I'm not a fan either. You know?
Yeah. I mean, we don't need to go
into start discussing template in languages, but a
lot of other languages have kind of just
adopted Jinja or some form of Jinja, and
that works relatively well. But Go, we just
went a completely different route. And it goes
against Yeah. What I'm familiar with for So
all these tool
it's like all these tools, like because I
get frustrated too. It's like I get frustrated
with Kubernetes because, like, Kubernetes fundamentally just is
kind of, like, raw verbose thing you have
to deal with. Or I get frustrated with
Helm.
And and it's like you know, because people
have said, like, well, you know, why don't
you commit to, like, core Kubernetes and make
it better? And it's like, well, I can't
necessarily make it better because, like, it is
what it is. Like, it is as powerful
and as successful as it is because of
the raw and verbose nature because it's like,
it's a platform that does everything for everyone.
So, like,
I don't think there's anything, like, funded like,
because all I'm saying, like, I'm trying to
make running apps on Kubernetes easier. It's like,
I don't think there's anything fundamentally wrong with
Kubernetes. It's just there's not a proper, like,
application abstraction on top of Kubernetes that exists
today. And, like, everyone who's done that has
basically kind of failed.
And, like, my kinda hypothesis there is that
is people that focus too much on CRDs
and Kubernetes APIs,
that that kinda laid you down a dark
path that's, like, kind of not compatible with
a lot of things. Because I I failed
in the same way. There was another project
I did a couple years ago called Rio
where I was trying to address kind of
this application layer.
And that you know, there were some interesting
things we did there, but all in all,
it was not what I wanted it to
be. And kinda my takeaway from that was,
like, if I'm really focusing on application,
you
can't get too much into the weeds of
Kubernetes. Like, you need to abstract yourself. So,
like, with Acorn, we took a stronger approach
of, like, let's provide a proper abstraction layer.
Like, we're not doing with Kubernetes YAML.
We have our own DSL.
You can largely
survive with just like, if you're, like, an,
just deploying apps, you can largely just survive
with, like, the Acorn tool.
But it was yeah. Yeah.
You're right. Kubernetes kinda gives us these, like,
primitives to pods, replicates, deployment services. I think
there is, like, pretty much 90% of what
any application developer really needs to deploy your
application, but we do have this whole what
that I mean, that's probably less than 1%
of the number of
resource definitions that are actually out there for
the Kubernetes environment.
And we have seen Yep. Other composite style
resources.
Like, I'm pretty sure there was an application
CRD spec from at one point or was
being developed.
But I don't think I've ever seen a
Yeah. Date.
So But, like, that's like, that like, so
the problem is, like, when you get to
this application layer is, like, you really have
to start applying some opinion.
Like, it's really hard to come up with,
like, let's create the specification that everyone agrees
on and can do everything.
You know? Like, there's gotta be so it's
very difficult. Like, I don't expect, like, the
app sync to, like, you know, kind of
be able to do that kind of design
by committee of the of figuring out, you
know, this layer because it becomes so much
a nuance. Because a lot of people ask,
like, well, you know, there's tons of solutions
that try to simplify the application layer.
You know, why is Acorn different? And it's
like, can tell you a bunch of, like,
technical differences in our approach or whatever. But,
fundamentally, it's like, well, I I think we
have a unique approach,
and that's subjective,
and we'll see if people like it. So
it's like, you know, hopefully, try Acorn, and
they like it. And if they don't like
it, then it wasn't good. Know?
Nice. We we actually have a a comment
in the chat for Bob then who was
about to ask if you know about Rio
and whatever happened to it. So at least
there's a couple of people watching that are
familiar with the work there.
Oh, yeah. Well, I mean, I mean, I
don't know I don't know if you realize.
So I wrote Rio. Like, that was my
that was so the the the backstory is
k three s came from Rio. So it
was kind of like Rio was a failure,
but as a side effect of that of
that project came k three s. So we're
like, well, I guess that was a success
in that, like, we got something out of
it. But Rio,
it was fundamentally,
I don't think that the timing was right
for it because
we started Rio as being a a more
abstracted thing,
but users just consistently wanted the raw access
to Kubernetes. They're like, no. I wanna be
able to have access to Kubernetes.
And
and we I mean, I didn't think that
was the best so it's like we basically
kinda morphed it to be more Kubernetes like,
which then basically kind of destroyed any of
the things we were trying to do.
So so now I think the timing's different
in that, like,
one, the shiny cool factor of of Kubernetes
is going down. It's not like the new
hotness.
So there's a lot of people who are
just, like, you know, been there, done that.
They're like, I've done deployments a million times,
and I would just like something easier.
The other thing is Kubernetes continues to, you
know, get adopted. Like, there's no there's, like,
no slowing it down right now, And there's
just more and more users coming into the
space who don't
you know, they're not like the early adopters
who level you know, it's like, they just
kinda wanna get things done. They're looking for
simpler approaches. So there's there's a so the
kind of the the timing is different now
where we can actually, I think, produce a
tool that's provides a more abstracted experience that's
that's simpler.
Okay.
So
one last question, and then we'll we'll actually
let you share your screen, and we'll take
a look at Acorn. But I'm curious about
not that I need that minute by minute
account of the night you went, screw this.
I'm gonna write on your tool. But I'm
assuming you said you were frustrated. And there
are tools out there that I think are
quite decent, you know, that we got Pulumi,
which of course I work for, so I'm
always gonna mention them. And CDK Yeah. Which
has been growing adoption, which allows us to
build these kind of abstractions.
Are these things that you've played with? And
then there was, like, this
point where you went, well, that's not what
I need. I need something else. So what
was Yeah.
Yeah. So I I mean, there's a good
point, like, Pulumi, CDK,
Terraform. Those kind of tools in my mind,
they all kind of operate at the infrastructure
space. So they're really good for, like, managing
clouds and and things like that. I think
when you get because, like, what you see
a lot of times is, like, those kind
of tools are basically setting up all the
infrastructure, the cloud, and all that, like, the
all the cloud resources. And then it's kinda
like those will then basically set up a
pipeline, and now your pipeline for your application
deployments is following, like, a different
a slightly different procedure using, like, GitOps and
or tilt or or whatever dev spaces. There's
there's a couple different dev tools I fooled
around with.
So I think, you know, I like, I
don't think, like, those those tools are are
really the same domain as, like, the application
deployment and, like like,
just the pure app layer.
I mean, I could be wrong,
but that's kind of my my my opinion
on it or whatever.
But the when you get to the
like, the just Kubernetes
development tools,
the problem that I see is that, like
I mean, they're very they're raw. They're very
diff like, basically, like, let's say, like, something
like Tilt. It's kind of like what you
need to do to use something like Tilt
is you first kinda have to have a
Kubernetes deployment.
Like so you already have to have an
expert in Kubernetes
who could kinda define how this application is
gonna be deployed.
So then you kinda move that back into
development, and then you set up the tilt
file to say, okay. How am I gonna
iterate on this
this
this application in in development?
So it's kind of like it it starts
from, like, the ops side or somebody who
really knows Kubernetes and then moves back to
the developers.
And so it's like, by the time you
get to the developers, it's like it's kind
of an odd experience. Like, it works for
someone who just, like, basically, like, I can
do a git clone, and I just run
this thing. But they don't really know what's
going on. They don't really change anything. It's
just like you know, it's it's just basically
insert code here.
So there's, like, that approach, but and I
I don't see those tools have been, like,
super popular. They haven't really caught on. Like,
the the biggest container oriented dev tool that
I've seen is is that's by far the
most popular is Docker Compose.
And but so you see still today a
lot of developers are using Docker Compose on
their laptop.
But then once they go to production, they
still do Kubernetes,
or maybe they're still in ECS.
But if they move to Kubernetes, it's like
then they switch to, like, Helm and and
customize and whatever, and then it like, there's
a lot of disconnect and friction there.
Okay.
Yeah. I think maybe in my head then,
I I had Acorn
slightly in the the wrong place. I wasn't
thinking about it as a tool similar to
DevSpace until
Docker Compose, but now that I'm thinking about
it, it does kind of satisfy that
local experience.
Does it move into the cluster as well?
Like, is Acorn a tool that can use?
Yeah.
Yeah. So it's both. So the thing is
is, like so fundamentally, what Acorn is technology
is, like, at the heart of it, it's
an application package. So it's like we actually
build and package up an application as an
OCI artifact, like a Docker image. You can
push and pull the whole thing as a
Docker image.
So it's kind of like it's it's like
a two headed beast. It's like on one
side, we have a package that's easy to
create for like, development can interact with it.
If you can do Docker Compose, you can
interact with Acorn.
But then on the other side, it's a
package that, like, the ops or DevOps team
can take and very easily deploy. It's a
very well known unit. It's well defined. It's
secured by default.
It has, like you know, it's like the
it's like something you can trust because
well, you know, it's alpha software, so don't
trust it very much. But, like but the
idea is is to get there because it's
like I I wanted you know? So it's
like it's kinda like as as applications are
coming from your app teams. Because I see
this within the enterprise perspective. Like, they have
difficulty onboarding a lot of app teams. So
you have, like, this one central, like, team
that manages Kubernetes, and they have to onboard
all these app teams. And so it's like,
if the applications are developed using Acorn, then
they can just very easily give that to
the op team, and they'll know exactly how
to run it. It integrates very well into
all the Kubernetes stuff, GitOps, everything,
but it's, a very well known unit. Whereas,
like, a Helm chart is kind of, like,
giving like, if you had the Helm chart
to, like, your op you know, just, like,
deploying production, it's the equivalent of basically giving
a shell script. It's just like
you know,
it's it's very difficult.
It's like you don't really know what it's
gonna do, so then you have to put
in a lot of, you know, guardrails around
that, you know, auditing and and, you know,
make sure you the RBAC and, you know,
all this stuff. So
but, yeah, hopefully, as I demo it, like
like, it'll become a little bit more clear
what it is. Well, yeah, you you said
lots of really cool things there that I'm
quite excited about. The fact that you're pushing
things to as an OCI artifact to registry,
I think, of where we're moving. I see
all these gaps. So those are the nests.
Now we're seeing this from flux. We're seeing
it from Argo. This just seems to be
like the new the new standard. So I
think what we do is we let you
share your screen. You give us the Yep.
Overview of how this all works, and and
then we can get some more questions back.
Okay. So let me share
share my screen. Minimize
that so we don't get nested. I'm gonna
do just one slide so you get a
visual representation, and then I'll go into just
programming. I'm not gonna do, like, slide where
Oh, your slides are up, so either way.
Yeah. Let me see. Did that work? From
okay.
Yeah. Whatever. You can just see it. So,
basically, the whole idea of the Acorn is,
like, we start with an Acorn file. You
notice, like, Acorn file kinda sounds like Dockerfile.
It's even written in the same style. You'll
see as I demo this, like, we took
tons of inspiration from Docker and Docker Compose
in the user experience
because, honestly, I think those are incredible tools.
From a like,
I haven't seen any other tool. Like, I
mean, just the fact that the way that
people can pick up and learn Docker so
quickly and use it, become productive,
you know, it's like there's something to be
admired there, and so we kind of copied
a lot of that. So the the basic
idea is you have an Acorn file, which
is like your the the equivalent of, like,
the Docker file today will build an image,
whereas the Acorn file will build, an application.
And the Acorn file can reference Docker files,
so you can also build the images as
you're building the the application.
So, basically, we run that. We create the
Acorn image, which is an OCI artifact,
and so it does include all of the
Docker images associated. So you get one image,
like one digest, one thing to sign.
That's completely you know, as you're moving around
environments, you you can you know, you know
it's the exact same thing.
It's
it's not like a Helm chart where, like,
the Helm chart is just the metadata, which
then references images, and then those images can
change as you move around. And you have
to worry about, like, mirroring con mirroring content
if you wanna do offline, like, air gap
setups and stuff like that. But, anyway, so
we we push that image to an OCA
registry.
So once it's up there in the registry,
then you can run it from any cluster,
any Kubernetes cluster. We just need, like, the
Acorn runtime, which is effectively just an operator
or controller, whatever you wanna call it.
So it does require admin privileges to install
that. I'm fooling around with, like, a solution
that doesn't require admin. But, like, right now,
it requires admin
to install the runtime on the on the
Kubernetes cluster. But once you have that, then
then you can you can run these apps.
So, like, that's, like, the 10,000 foot view
of kind of what Acorn is.
I
can just go right into demoing it now
if you want. Okay.
Yeah. And please, like, stop me, ask questions,
or or whatever.
Yeah. Of course.
Because I I have a 10 like, I'll
just keep going and talking and do out
a million things. So if you wanna
so the way to install this, the easiest
way is just through Brew,
or you can go to the the GitHub
page, and there's binaries you can download. So
we have Windows Windows,
Mac, and Linux
and the architectures,
whatever. So you just install with Brew.
I already have it installed,
obviously.
Once you have it, you do need a
Kubernetes cluster. So if you're fully on this
on your laptop,
Docker desktop or Rancher desktop should work
just out of the box.
You know, if you have any weird issues,
you know, go to our GitHub issues, discussions,
or Slack channel, and we'll help you out.
We're doing our best because, like,
you know, there's so many different styles of
clusters. And so it's like if you do,
like, minikube or kind, there's a couple more
steps you need to do because we need
an ingress controller.
But we're trying to document that all. But
I just know if, like, the simplest experience
is Docker desktop or Rancher desktop right now.
Yeah.
Okay. But to install it, you're just gonna
run, like, Acorn install.
And this is where I said you need
the runtime.
So this is gonna install the runtime on
the cluster. I already have it installed, so
that just, you know, went super fast or
whatever.
But so now
now I have this, and I can start
fooling around with it. So if
let me just show you kinda the high
level of the commands.
I'm not gonna go through each one individually,
but it's like you see things like log
in, log out, push pull, tag,
run,
build. So, basically, it follows a very similar
type. So if you're familiar with building Docker
containers
and pushing and pulling those, Acorn's gonna feel
very comfortable because you're basically doing, like, a
very similar thing. We're building eight application images
and running them.
So let me show you this little
this sample that we have. So this
I'll I'll I'll go through. If we have
enough time, I'll show you kind of, like,
two different things. Like, this first is, like,
a a good like, this is actually the
app from our getting started guide,
but it's gonna show you kind of, like,
a development flow of, like, packaging up, like,
a Flask app or something like that. I
have another example in here, which is, like,
gonna make more sense to someone who's more,
like, DevOps oriented, which is gonna be running
Jenkins,
like, a a, you know, a Jenkins with
the Kubernetes cloud and configuration code, like,
that whole setup.
And and that one's, like, more complicated, but
I'll I'll get to that. So for this
little
application,
so we have, like, just some dumb little
Flats gap in here.
And then we have a Docker file to
build this app. So, again, very simple. Just,
you know, copying this over, running TIP.
Okay. So now let's look at our Acorn
file. And there's
quite a bit in here to begin with,
and I'll kind of walk through so you
can get an idea of, like, what we're
seeing in here. Because this is kind of,
like,
somewhat of, like, a tour de force of
the syntax. It's just throwing in a lot
of things at once. But the first thing
you'll notice is the syntax. So the syntax
is
it's kinda like a JSON.
It's a superset of JSON, so it kinda
follows JSON.
We're we're really heavily inspired by q.
I can go into quite a, like, a
a long spiel about why exactly it's not
q, but, like, we very much like q.
We're huge fans of q. I've done a
lot of work with q. And so the
syntax here is
kind of inspired
greatly
by q, but it it is it is
not actually q.
So
but the syntax since it's like it's kinda
like JSON like. It should
I I we haven't really seen much people,
like, struggle with, like, learning that. It's all
documented if you go to our docs. But
what I have here in this Acorn file,
I'll start off. We have
ARMs at the top. So ARMs are
it's kinda like the equivalent of your helm
values. If you wanna pass in parameters at
build or deploy time,
the you can define ARGs, and then people
can can reference those. I'll show you the
ARGs, how they work after I build this.
But so at this top level here, I've
defined containers, and I have basically three containers.
I have this first one, which is the
app,
which this is the the Postgres app. No.
I'm sorry. The Flask app that talks to
Postgres.
And and so there are couple things going
on here. First is I'm doing build. I'm
gonna build this from the Docker container.
I'm setting some environment variables. You'll see some
interesting syntax here. Like, I'm pulling in some
secrets. I'll just explain that just a little
bit. And this here's where I'm referencing that
bar to get the the welcome.
And then you can see a little condition
here of, like, if args, whatever.
This is
this
this is so, like, when we're running this
in development mode, it's gonna be slightly different
than if we build it for production.
And I'll show you what I'll talk about
what development mode is later.
You can have depends on. This just starts
this is controls the update and starting order
of things.
In development, we wanna cop live sync over
some files, and this is how we basically
publish the port. So these other ones here,
this is a Reddit cache, and this is
Postgres. I'm not gonna go into detail on
those, but let's get into actually building the
application.
So if I wanna build this, I can
I can tag it as something?
I don't really need to yeah. I'll I'll
tag it just as, like, demo right now.
So we'll go and build this. So this
is going it's doing, like, it's doing the
Docker build that was include that the Acorn
file referenced, and then it's also building the
final,
application, which is the the one the one
image.
So,
so I should see now when I view
this oh, I just it was this one
right here. I just built that demo image.
So now I can run this. So I
can just say Acorn run,
demo.
And now if I just kinda watch the
output here
oops. Mac's
on that watch, I guess.
So this is coming up, and then, hopefully,
this is oh, this is Docker. Can I
pop in for a second?
Yeah.
So the first thing is we're kinda missing
the first line and the last line of
your terminal. Could you, like, just Oh, shoot.
Roll your window a little bit so it's
not as tall?
I don't know. I think the aspect ratio
is a bit weird, and I've been trying
to work around it, but I can't quite
get it. Okay. Sorry about that. Well, what
I can do let me not let me
do what's the there's, like, a diff
no. There's another
may no. Is that better? Is it is
it or is it still chopped off? Yeah.
The bottom the first line and the last
lines need to be chopped off. If you
just, like, make it less tall, so just
drag it up a little bit.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Alright. Come
on.
Why can't I select alright. Okay. There
we go.
That's it. Okay. Perfect. Thank you. Is that
it? Oh, okay. Oh, that's terrible. So you
couldn't see the commands I was typing? Well,
we we were lucky. We could see, like,
90%.
It was just when you, like, cleared the
screen, the first command, and then when it
got filled the screen, we missed the last.
But it was okay. We we followed along.
We're still working. So
Okay. So
so you can see here
so I built the application,
and then I ran it. So now I'm
running it. And you'll see, like, we we
in the application definition let me go back
to the Acorn file real quick. I defined
publish HTTP.
If you do HTTP under the hood, it's
gonna use ingress, which then,
requires, like, DNS. And so we automatically do
a bunch of tricks with DNS.
So you get
oh, wow. The default terminal is terrible on
a Mac. I can even click on the
URL.
I don't use Macs. I I I use
a I use Linux, but I had to
switch to it for this for this thing.
I had some problem.
Internal server error. Oh, okay. Wait. Here's the
server.
Why is it doing that? Let's see let's
see why that's.
Oh,
oh, okay.
Okay. We'll we'll we'll fix that. So there's
there's a little problem in the in the
apple in the application.
But
but, anyways so we'll I'll I'll show you.
We'll fix that. And so we can kind
of go into the the development mode.
Okay. So so the idea is
as I said, you can,
you know, you rerun run the app, and
then we give you a URL, and then
you can get get into it
get into the app.
So if I wanted to update this application,
like, if I made some some change or
whatever
so, basically, you would just go through the
flow. Like, you know, if I wanted to,
you know, put some something in here, then
you can go
and, you know, build this again. I'll do.
So, like, this will go build your application
again.
And then I can just go and update.
I think I missed the.
Update.
Let me say image,
right, demo two,
and then
that will then update it. So the that's
kinda like the manual flow of, like you
know, so you can build, push,
and whatever.
So this is all, like, going to the
CLI. I want to point out under the
hood, this is, like, a % Kubernetes architecture.
There's a Kubernetes API under there and all
that stuff. So if you, you know, you
wanna get into, like, and GitOps and all
this stuff or whatever, it's all completely compatible.
The the Acorn like, the CLI is just,
like, a really nice experience on top of
the API,
but it's it's all standard stuff under the
hood. But so
so what I wanted to show is so
I just did, like, a manual of, like,
build it and then then update it. What
you can do is if you're running this,
like, in a development mode
let me just delete the app.
Let me just delete everything. Okay. So what
we can do is we can run this
in a development mode, and this is gonna
be much closer to, like, a Docker Compose
app. So you can do dash dash dev.
The short form of that is I, which
is kind of a little weird, but
and I'm gonna actually I'm gonna call it,
a demo so we have a nice little
name or whatever. So now this is gonna
run this in a in a
in a, development mode. And so what you
can do is, like, this will build it
and bring up the application,
and then it will
live you know, tail everything that's going on.
Let's wait for the the it Ingress control
or NGINX Ingress controller is super slow to
provision.
Like
so that it's that's why it says pending.
It's waiting on the ingress controller to assign
to assign something.
There we go. So now it's up. Okay.
Just
copy that.
Go back here.
Oh,
I don't know. I don't know what the
deal is.
Scram authentication
requires
version 10 or above.
Am I running let me just see if
I'm running them.
Guess okay. And your requirements.
Yeah. I don't know.
So
why
is it even doing authentication?
I think it's Okay. Well, let's let's talk
to like, maybe let me look at this.
I don't know.
This is one of those things. You know?
It's like, well, it was working yesterday.
So let me talk about, like, the authentication
and stuff. Like, this is the authentication
of what's what's failing. So you can see
here,
where we started up Postgres, and we're using
oh,
let me make sure
okay. I'll get back get back to that
one in a second. I might be using
an old data volume.
But so so
you can see here the secrets. So we've
defined the secret here called quick start PG
pass or whatever, and it's of type token.
So what we do with secrets is, like,
we wanna by default
we want apps to kinda work out of
the box and securely.
So we have a couple of built in
secret types that will just generate a value
for you. So this one, it just generates
a token, and there's parameters. You can control
what characters and how long,
but it just generates a random a random
token.
So so what this is doing so this
secret, it generates this token,
and then we can pass that secret,
the token value to the password here,
and then we can also pass the same
thing here to
the the password up here.
So that works for, like, development. It'll automatically,
like, like, generate the secret. At in production,
you can then bind in secrets. So, like,
as part of, like, the run command,
you can do things here where you bind
in secrets. So if you have an existing
secret, like, you know, it's
you can create the secret if you want
using the RCLI,
but under the hood, they're they're still just
Kubernetes secret. So it's like, you know, if
you're doing sealed secrets or external secrets or,
you know, whatever whatever crazy way you wanna
manage secrets, you can manage those independently and
then just bind them into the application, and
you'll use them.
Okay.
So so let me show let's see if
we can
I wonder if we can figure out why
this? It says SCRM authentication
requires
libpk version
10 or above.
So I wonder if, like, it's a new
version of
Postgres.
Should we try? Do you know anything about
about
Very good. Let me check.
Let me see. I wonder I wonder let
me try, like, not the PostgreSQL.
No. Let's see. Is your Kubernetes
cluster on is that local? Is it Docker
for Mac?
Yeah. Yeah. It's just a Docker for Mac.
Yeah. Okay. So it apparently is an m
one problem.
It's an m one problem?
Oh, okay.
Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense. So, apparently, if
if you're happy to rebuild your images, you
have to export docker underscore default underscore platform
equals one app slash e m d 64
and then do a rebuild of your images,
and that will remove the error.
So I'm assuming your Python app has been
But I can't
It's not 64. But I can't
yeah. So that won't work. Well, okay. Well,
that that's fine. I mean, that whatever. So
the app is failing. That's an arm arm
issue, whatever. But at this point, we
can talk about multi arc.
We basically we we can like, if you
wanna build like, if I want to build
this I mean, I can I can build
it for AMD sixty four, but the problem
is I won't
it doesn't really help because I can't run
it?
But
right? I don't think I can run an
AMD sixty four on I don't think that
works in Docker or whatever. But
but, anyways but, yeah, so if, like, I
actually wanted to build am I still in
this app? So
if I wanted to build this application and
I wanted to support,
both,
Linux AMD sixty four
and
Linux
ARM 64,
and then let's just tag this as we'll
actually show, like, pushing the I build the
cloud. Demo
test.
So this will actually go and build both
architectures and then combine it into one image.
So, I mean, we're this is all standard
OCI stuff, so we are using manifest lists
and all that under the hood. So we
just basically are pulling in the different the
requirements from from different
I mean, we're sorry. No. The requirements. I
just read that. We're pulling in the images
from different architectures and then just linking them
all together.
So I think that just did the AMD
one, and now, yeah, it's probably doing that.
Or, yeah, now it's doing the arm one
maybe.
But if I actually wanna push this so,
like, I just built this image as
so
now I can actually push it.
And
this first one that will fail because I
don't have
oh, sorry. There's one one tiny little thing
that I forgot.
You have to put the full
registry in there, like Docker.io.
We don't have a default namespace. Like, that's
been, like, a big problem with Docker
in general is the default namespace always goes
to Docker IO. So
so we just decided we're just not gonna
have a default namespace.
So that's why that that push failed, but
this will fail also because I haven't logged
in.
It's gonna
it'll end up oh, wait. No. I guess
I have. Oh, I already used this. That
was that was nice. Oh,
yeah. Because I already had this set up.
Okay. So
so that's
that's kind of the basic flow. I mean,
are you kind of getting the the the
over
kind of the overview of kinda how Acorn
works? And
Yeah. I think so. I I'd like to
take a few steps back and slow down
and just kinda cover everything. Although, I'm slightly
worried that you've frozen these now there.
Oh, yeah. Let me let me just cancel
that because it's trying to push up the
content.
Yeah. Yeah. Got it. So let's take a
few steps back. Let's pop open the Acorn
file, and I've got a couple of questions
from and there, and then we'll take a
look at the template. And if anyone watching
us live has any questions, feel free to
drop them into the comments, and we'll get
around to them Yeah. Shortly.
Alright. So the first question is, you mentioned
us earlier.
It looks like q. You like q, but
it's not q. I also like q. So
I'm curious.
Why have you got
why is it not just q? What were
the what was the thinking there?
So the scope of queue, like, queue
I mean, it's an amazing language, and the
scope of queue, like
basically, what it comes down to
is
queue the whole fundamental thing about is, like,
unification.
It's, like, unification disjunctions.
It works so it's combining the idea of,
like, schema and data into this one thing,
and it's, like, really beautifully well done. I
very much like it. So kind of the
problem with queue is that
all of the unique and cool features of
it, we don't actually need.
We really just need a language that's kinda
much closer to to JSON. But
we like the style of queue better. Like,
they're it's kinda a little more elegant and
simpler in the in the approach.
So
when so one of the number one feedbacks
we got as we kind of started building
Acorn, we showed it to people, is,
it's, like, basically the difficulty of queue because
you start getting into all of, like, the
schema and all those other things that basically
they didn't need.
And so
there's all this stuff
in queue that we don't need that basically
kinda confuses users. But then on top of
it, it leads to a lot of unexpected
behavior for people.
Like, so, fundamentally,
what we got back there he's like, there's
two there's two
feedback we always got. Was one is they
want an else statement,
which is funny, but a q doesn't have
an else statement. Statement. Just has if.
And then the second one was
was that they really wanna be able to
override data. But, fundamentally, you can't override data
in queue.
But, like, when you get into more complex
examples where you're dealing with config files and
stuff, that it it becomes kind of obvious
that you wanna be able to change keys
in different in different situations or whatever. So,
basically, as, like, we went through it, like,
our needs like, I love q, but, like,
our needs of what we need for Acorn
don't really fully align with, like, what q
is and where q is going.
Because even, like, those two little small things,
like, overriding data or the if blocks, there's
reason or the else blocks. The reason why
they don't exist is because of, you know,
good reasons for q, but, like, those reasons
are not applicable to us. So
in
order to, like, kinda optimize the user experience
for users
like, this was a difficult decision, but we
basically came to a conclusion that we should
just kinda charge for our with our own
language.
And so far, we've gotten kind of really
no pushback or issue with that.
Yeah. I mean, I I like the release
the queue. It feels
yeah. It works well for me. In fact,
I'm pretty confident I could run queue eval
on that file, and it probably would just
work most,
at least from what I can see right
now. And being right about the test junctions,
those are runs that still trip me up,
and I've been using q a long time,
and I'm sure even worse for people that
are new to the language. Because the error
messages from q can sometimes lead you down
some awkward
paths.
Very confusing. Yeah. Yeah. So, I mean, I've
written, like, thousands and thousands of line. Yeah.
It's like, I I've done a lot of
queue. And internally,
we actually still use queue for some
data, like, SKU validation and things like that.
But, yeah, like, the the error messages are
are kind of difficult,
and it's not just because
yeah. And it's kind of hard hard to
solve solve those things because the the it's
just, the fundamental nature of what they're trying
to do, like, unifying data
or unifying the the the values or whatever.
So Cool. But
but I very much so it's like it's
like a very much like queue, but it
just didn't work out for this use case.
Alright. I'm happy with that. Alright. I've got
a couple more questions from here, and then
we'll jump into the comments. So we've got
these
I'm gonna call them generators, but your secret
stuff here. What
I'm really curious about is we've seen the
token type which generates some arbitrary string, which
I think you said could be configured,
which is really cool.
Does it do x five zero nines? That
would be pretty awesome.
Okay.
So we actually had x five zero nine
built in,
but
we ended up deleting it because we can't
it's kinda weird. We couldn't find, like, a
super obvious thing. So what like, what's your
use case where you want x five zero
nine?
Because you couldn't find, like, cause I built
it. So I'm like, oh, I could totally
use that.
Yeah. Maybe it's it's super niche, but working
on mutation mutation and mission controllers where you
have to have to see and then drop
the bundle into the CRD. And I know
that cert manager has the injector, and you
can do that.
I don't have cert manager in my local
Yeah. Yeah. Development clusters.
So that would be my use case there.
But maybe that's too niche for what this
product is done. Yep.
Well, so so I had this the same
thing where it's like, I've done all these
things where it's like, oh, it'd be cool
if I had x five zero nine. So
it's like, we actually built it in. You
could generate CA certificates and then sign certificates
from it and all this stuff.
But we ended up taking it out because
it seemed like the the majority of those
use cases ended up being very infrastructure oriented,
and they weren't really needed for the application.
So, like, the way that we're kind of
taking the approach on on encryption and all
that stuff is that well, one, like, the
application doesn't like like, what I don't like,
what we don't really want is, like, the
application to, like, let's say, generate a TLS
certificate and use that for serving, like, serving
out because, like, that's handled by, like, the
ingress controller, like, the ingress infrastructure or, you
know, something external to Kubernetes. So it's like
the application doesn't really need to be aware
of, like, encrypting its public endpoint.
I'm sure there's corner cases where you you'll
you'll say I'm wrong. But, like, for the
general general case, it's like, it doesn't seem
like, most of that stuff should be handled
by the platform.
And so, like, one of the features that's
coming out in the zero dot two or
zero dot three release of of Acorn
is gonna be, like, automatic TLS generation. Like,
we already integrate really well with cert manager.
So if you're already using cert manager today,
like, the integration is pretty straightforward.
But, like, we wanted to make it even
easier for our users where, like, for the
default use cases, the simpler use cases, we
just automatically create TLS.
So so we do that on the public
side. Now if you look at the internal
communication of, like, container to container within
the cluster,
we're leaning much more towards service mesh in
that situation because it's like we've designed Acorn
such that we can plug in a service
mesh and then then wire up all of
the service RBAC rules.
And then so it's like, basically, you'll get
MTLS
plus service authorization,
like, for free, basically. You just run, like,
the, you know, like, STO Acorn plug in,
and we'll program all those rules.
So, like, when we look at, like, container
to container communication, like, I kinda also don't
want containers to be doing TLS themselves because
it's like, well, I can still hardly do
that with with service
mesh and basically do a better job.
So Okay. Yeah. But if if the use
case comes back up, like, if we get,
like, request for it from users or whatever,
then we'll bring it back. We just yeah.
It's in Git the Git history. We just
we kinda deleted it right now. So
Alright. No. Your that makes sense. Definitely.
Okay. Couple more questions for me and then
comments. What's the difference between local data and
ARDs?
Yeah. Yeah. So local data. So this is,
like, kind of, like, a just a total
gratuitous use of the syntax.
And so
so, basically, ARDs is information that you pass
in. So this can be passed into the
user. I didn't actually show this. It's, like,
when you build the application. So, like, I
built this application here from this. I can
say,
run
and then help.
And then it creates the args on the
application. So this is like so when I
deploy this application, I can pass in an
argument
and change it. Okay? So so the args
are are designed for, like, external or your
input. Local data is just, like, just random
stuff that you can just put in here.
So a lot of times when we build
things,
like, I'll go to a a more
more complicated example, which is the Jenkins one.
Let's see. So, like, in the local data,
like, here, I have, like, the tax
the configuration as code
configuration in there.
And so I have that data in there,
and I can do, like, you know, logic
and manipulation of that.
But then
afterwards,
I then basically
turn that into YAML and stick it into
a secret. So local beta is just kinda
help
help you can just put crap in there
whenever you want to kinda help with your
package.
Okay.
One
last question then.
Can we go back to the simple Acorn
file?
And that you list a bunch of containers.
Yeah. Yeah. We got, you know, cache DB.
Can you run, like, web control get pods?
Is that one pod with multiple containers, one
pod, multiple pod?
Like, what does that Oh, no.
So, like yeah.
So
yeah. So under the hood
let's see. So under the hood let's see.
I'll first show you the namespace so you
understand. So when we deploy an application, we
actually
like, this
how does what's the syntax here at? No.
No. No. Sorry.
Yeah. There we go. Okay. So the the
CRD that we're actually creating under the hood
is just Acorn app.
Okay. So this is created in the Acorn
namespace.
But when we create the application
yeah. There's too much garbage in there to
to show you. But but, basically, every
app gets deployed into its own namespace. So,
like, you create the app like, the the
app CRD is in is in, like, the
user namespace.
And then for each each application, we then
create a new namespace.
Okay. So if I look at the namespaces
because this, like, this keeps the service discovery
keeps the service discovery very clear,
like, very simple and portable, and it also
helps with security.
It's very easy to lock down the applications
because we have one namespace per app. And
then we handle all the heavy cross service
discovery across
namespace and stuff like that. That that's, like,
more advanced topics. But so I have this
app in here. So it created this namespace.
So if I look in here, you'll see
I have three different pods.
If I look at the deployments, you can
see the deployments are, like, exactly so it's
like the app. So the container is actually
mapped to the to pods.
And so the the reason why we called
it containers is
it just makes a lot more sense to
users than getting into, like, the difficulties of
pods. But you can do if you want,
you can do sidecars.
Okay. So you can put in, like, sidecar
foo,
and then so you can still get the
full power, and you can also do you
can create init containers. You just say init
true.
Wow. So you can you can, you know,
use the full power of pods.
But, like, we don't enter like, we don't
because, like, the side like, the pods and
the sidecar pattern or something is super powerful.
Right? But it's kind of like it's like,
you don't get it until you actually need
it. So it's like, we don't shove it
down people's throat. Like, you need to understand
a pod. It's like, no. Just want containers.
And then at some point, they're like, oh,
but I really want this container to always
be next to it. And it's like, oh,
that's a sidecar.
You know? So, anyway, so that's that's that's
what we have.
So you also see, like, under the hood,
like, what it's doing of, like if I
look at services. Okay? So it's like, we
create services of the exact same name, like,
like, this so it's like under the hood,
we're creating standard Kubernetes objects,
and they're using the same names as what's
in the the Acorn file. Because, again, since
we're using our own namespace, we can do
that. It's, like, they're unique within the Acorn
files, and they're they're also unique within the
namespace.
So it's, like, most of the stuff that
we're wiring up is pretty straightforward. It's, like,
ingress services, config maps, secrets. We just deal
with all the, like, the core types.
Yeah. So it's like, if you understand Kubernetes,
like, what this produces is pretty straightforward and
obvious. Like, it's not
madness. It's not like this super heavy layer
on top of Kubernetes. It's a very light
layer.
It's just enforcing, like, a lot of good
standards and and stuff like that.
Sweet. Okay.
Let's talk So it's like from a security
purse sorry. Yeah.
Go ahead.
I was just gonna say we could tackle
a few of the comments that I've come
in from the people watching. But if you
wanna tackle some if you wanna mention some
security stuff, please feel free.
Oh, no. I was saying from, like, a
security perspective, like, the things that we do,
it's like, can't run privileged containers.
By default,
the applications have no access to Kubernetes.
You don't, like, you know, get permissions. There
is I can show you a way to
get permissions, and then it's very controlled if
you wanna get permission permissions to the to
the Kubernetes API.
And then on top of that, when we
create like, so I said, like, we create
a new namespace for each app.
So we go and if you look at
the namespace that's created, we automatically do the
baseline profile for pod security.
So those pods are are already enforced
that by Kubernetes that they can't do anything.
And so we're adding more things. Like, we're
gonna automatically program network policies, so you'll automatically
get the network policies. Because the definite the
definition of how Acorn is is, like, all
communication is explicit.
Going back to the Acorn file. Where was
it? Like, if I don't have this port
here,
then nothing can talk to it. Like, we
don't expose that port. But technically, if you
know the details of Kubernetes, it is technically
exposed. If you know the IP, you can
hit it or whatever. But but so the
idea is, like, the the the DSL describes
all the communication paths and what's exposed. So
then we can then go and enforce that
with, like, network policies or Cillium or Calico
or Istio. We can enforce all that stuff,
and we're building on kind of those integrations
into the lower levels.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. We can go into
the questions. Yeah. Well, I think we have
a question that kinda
touches and kinda segues off this quite nicely.
So you said that you can't have a
privileged container, and that's because the DSL doesn't
provide any sort of interface to
generate a privileged container.
So what Bob then asked very early in
the session was
the issue here potentially is how the comment's
gonna scroll off the screen. Sorry about that.
But what do you do if you need
to break out of the abstraction? What do
I need to do something that isn't exposed
by the Acorn interface? You got any any
thoughts there?
Well,
I mean so there is a way to
request permissions,
and then you can do that. But, like,
the intention okay. So there's a bigger
there's a bigger goal with Acorn in general.
It's like because, also, it's like, we have
a company, and we're gonna eventually try to
make money and stuff like that. Oh, yeah.
About this. Like, about that, just I just
wanna make something clear. Acorn, the project is
open source. It will never be, like, open
core. We're not gonna do crap like that.
Like, if you know our history with Rancher,
the people at Acorn Labs, it's a lot
of the same people. Actually, it's all the
same cofounders as Rancher. We're very dedicated open
source. Okay. So you don't have to worry
about that. Like but but it's, like, our
fundamental premise of, like, what we're trying to
do is, like what we see is that
it's effectively, the operations of Kubernetes is is
too difficult. It's like, there's just there's so
much power and flexibility in Kubernetes
that it leads to,
a lot of operational complexities of everyone is
kind of building,
all of this stuff around Kubernetes
to, like, how to deploy applications and validate
it and and do upgrades and create pipelines
and all this stuff. And so our fundamental
premise is basically if, like, we can create
a simpler application unit that is fundamentally abstracted
from Kubernetes,
then we can drastically reduce the operational side.
And then at the end of the day,
that's what big enterprises and companies care about.
That's what they're gonna pay money for is
is if we can reduce the operational side.
So it's it's when you say, like, breaking
through the abstraction,
it's really important for us that the abstraction
actually works for all applications.
So where we draw the line is basically
if you need to do infrastructure oriented stuff,
that's gonna be, like, more of, like, a
that's that's gonna be, like,
right now, you can still just do everything
in Kubernetes, but we will be building kind
of, like, an Acorn system type thing where
you can do extensions and drivers and stuff
that will be more privilege oriented.
But for the Acorn file, it's like, we
don't do any, like, driver infrastructure
or store you know, like, don't do that
stuff. If your application needs access like, a
good way to look at it is, like,
if your application needs access to the Kubernetes
API,
then it's probably not just a pure application.
It's probably very oriented towards Kubernetes.
But there is a way to request permissions,
so you can request permissions and get access
to the Kubernetes API. But, like, once you
do that, you have to realize you're already,
like, kind of you're breaking the abstraction because
that thing can now do
a lot of things that could be really
bad.
So we're trying to actually create a
fairly strong abstraction layer, which I knew was
extremely difficult.
And and one of the the biggest questions
we always like, whenever we show Acorn to,
like, a real diehard Kubernetes thing, the first
thing Kubernetes uses, the first thing they're gonna
ask is what about CRDs?
And so
CRDs is something where it's like, well, if
we allow you to just create any CRD,
then it makes it such that, like,
this unit, this this Acorn app app that
we're deploying,
it no longer has a predictable behavior because
CRDs can do anything, and they don't have
a standard way that you interop interact with
them. Like, a very basic example is, like,
let's say I'm using the Kafka operator and
I wanted to create a Kafka instance.
If I put that CRD in my application
so when I deploy that app and then
I delete that app, it's gonna delete the
Kafka instance.
You know? That's bad. So, like, we go
through things where it's like like the way
the Acorns are designed is, like, if you
deploy the Acorn and then you delete it
and then you redeploy it,
the the state was stored in volumes and
secrets, which are not by default deleted when
the app is deleted. So if you, like,
mess up and accidentally delete it, which, like,
happens from, like, GitOps, people like, oops. You
know, wrong commit, and then they delete something.
You know, we protect you from that. So
it's like, you know, if you'd start doing
all these crazy things, then it's like, don't
you lose all the guarantees.
Okay.
I think in line with that, you mentioned
something there and earlier. You said the word
driver there, but you also mentioned, like,
Linkerd or Istio plugins earlier.
So there are extension points to kind of
Yeah. Alright. Okay. Is that something that Acorn
and Acorn Yeah. So that Sorry.
So that's the the extension points, that's all
in the works right now. So, like, we're
designing that out and doing that of, like,
how do we integrate all into. So,
yeah. So we're designing basically what's the plug
in mechanism so that you
can augment
because the idea is, like, if you have
this application definition,
can I create plug ins that basically take
that definition and then generate more resources?
So this is kinda, like, more of the
route that we're going with
with CRDs
is, like, if you need to do CRDs,
like your app
let's say you're using a very custom ingress
controller or something,
and so you need to be done a
certain way.
So
we would look at, like, the plug in
extension model
of, like, how do we generate different resources
or modify the existing resources based on your
specific configuration.
So so that's keeping the abstraction of, like
the application doesn't change, but, like, you have
a plug in in the infrastructure layer, which
can then kind of modify it. And that
will most likely
like, we'll have a an an approach where
you could you know?
I don't I I I won't talk too
much about it, but it's it's gonna be
really cool. The the the it's very it
should be really simple to write these extensions,
but I don't wanna get too much into
it. Okay. Let's tackle a couple more questions
then. So we got one from Javier here
who's asking, how do I handle scale?
I'm assuming they're looking for HPA support perhaps.
Well, I mean, so just the basic thing
is you can just put scale in here.
So you can just scale see, I'm saying
scale
is two.
And then if you wanna make it so
that's changeable, then you can say, you know,
scale to here and then
reference it like that. So then when you
deploy, you can change the scale.
But so so HPA support is definitely coming,
but it's not there yet. I mean, this
project's only, like, about three weeks old. So,
yes, we will be doing HPA and auto
scaling support. Like,
that's definitely on the road map, but just
not there yet. Because that's another one where
it's like yeah. It's super hard for people
to to get auto scaling right, and so
we wanna make this. So it's like auto
scaling blue green deployments, kind of, like, canary
and those type of things. Those are all
definitely on the road map of, like, addressing
it. Because, again, it just goes to the
idea of, like like, blue green or or
canary. Those are just, like, update models. Like,
fundamentally, your app definition shouldn't change. Like, that's
more of a how do you deploy and
run it? So it's like, you don't have
to build that into your you shouldn't have
to fundamentally build it into your application
how to do that. Like, the the platform
and runtime should be able to take care
of most of that.
Alright.
Next question.
What access to the cluster do I need
to be able to deploy an Acorn app?
Yeah. So right now, you do need admin
access. If you don't have admin access, you
can right now. It's just a shortcut, is
use vCluster.
So you can just run
vCluster and then run run Acorn inside of
vCluster, and there's no overhead or downside to
that.
That's what, like, I was saying I'm looking
at a way of trying to make it
work for just regular users, and that's what
we'll do as we'll effectively just wrap it
in vCluster.
But
but yeah. So you do need
you do need
kind of admin
access.
I will show you
specifically
what we need if I can figure
it out.
What's
sorry. This is not my normal work
working machine.
Okay. So this is specifically what what we
require,
which is access basically to our API groups,
some standard core stuff, and then we need
to be able to see the nodes,
CRDs,
API. Yeah. So, anyways, those those are the
the roles. So there's an actual, you know,
we do set up, like, a proper role
and role finding and all that stuff.
But, yeah, so you do need admin access
right now. But, again, if you don't have
admin access, you wanna try this out, run
vCluster.
VCluster doesn't require admin access at all.
V cluster from Loft, those guys.
Yeah.
Alright.
Next question.
Am I limited to create deployments as a
base for the resource application? I guess they're
looking or talking about stateful sets, daemon sets,
etcetera.
Okay. So
yeah. So we do we do it's so
okay. We
can do stateful applications, but we don't use
stateful sets. So this is kind of a
little different.
And there's a lot of reasons for that,
and maybe we'll find out that our reasons
are bad.
But in our example let me see.
So dogs,
there's,
let's see.
How how does one do this?
I know there's, like, advanced topics.
Stateful applications. Okay. So what we do is
okay.
Fundamentally,
the idea of a stateful application or what
stateful sets do is, like, why they're fun.
Why stateful sets are fundamentally different from deployments
is that a stateful set gives a gives
a
an identity
a fixed identity to each
container that's running.
And or and that and that identity is,
like, persistent. So if you delete it, it
will come back and has the same identity.
The identity is effectively just the DNS name.
So
the problem with stateful sets in in my
mind is that, like, it's kind of there's
not just one way to run stateful applications.
So sometimes stateful sets work, but sometimes, like,
your app is still more complicated than it
will work for a stateful set.
So our approach to stateful applications
is what we do is a little bit
more manual, but it gives you a huge
amount of flexibility. Because, like, we've tried, like,
running, like, Kafka, Cassandra,
MySQL,
Postgres,
Redis,
like, complicated setups, multi master.
We've we've tried running all these things in
in in Acorn, and we've gotten, you know,
largely to work. Like, you know, we've
we've we haven't run anything fundamental issue. Like,
we're not experts on all those systems, so
it's not all production grade. But, like but
we've been able to get them all set
up and everything.
And so the approach of what we do
is is kind of this trick here. It's
like, you you say, okay. If I want,
like, two replicas,
you just this is all again, this is,
like, queue queue syntax or whatever.
We go through well, it's close to queue.
This is not queue right here. But
we go through and we create a like,
you create a range of, like,
you know, three, and then you actually create
three separate,
like, in like, containers. So you say, like,
container one, container two, container three, and then
each one of those is going to bind
a different volume. So you get volume one,
volume two, volume three.
So it, like, effectively just created a stable
set. Each one has a stable identity,
and it has volumes associated with it. And
then there's also little tricks under the hood
where it's like, if it's
if it's an application of scale one if
it's a container of scale one and it's
using a rewrite only a rewrite once volume,
then we do, like, a replace strategy so
you don't get two two things trying to
access the data at the same time.
So, anyway, so our approach right now is
we're not actually using stateful sets under the
hood. You know, again, maybe we'll find out
that that was a stupid idea. But, like,
what we found is this pattern of effectively
kinda manually creating your stateful set ends up
being very powerful. So, again, like, one of
the reasons why it's so powerful is what
you can do is, like, in this if
loop here, is a lot of times you
have to bootstrap a system.
So, like, the first replica, you wanna run
that in the bootstrap mode, and the other
replicas you don't wanna run-in, like, the bootstrap
mode. So by basically looping through, you can
say, like, if I index is zero, like,
the first one, like, if I equals zero,
then add the Bootstrap Bootstrap arguments.
So you can configure
like, with the logic, just doing the logic
in here, you can configure the instances slightly
different,
which ends ends up being very useful to,
like, bootstrap clustered system. So it's like we've
been able to bring up yeah. So it's
like things like because, like, Cassandra or Cluster,
you know, those type of things. So I
can actually show you, like, a more
realistic
what this would look like because it it
starts getting
you know, like, as your apps like, running
the Stateful thing is is
complicated. It's never it's never easy running Stateful
stuff.
So these these examples are more complicated, but
it does get into the, like, what's capable.
So
here, it's like
oh, yeah. Sure.
But, yeah, this is actually a fully working
MariaDB that does Galera cluster onto the hood.
So, again, you can see this pattern of
we're doing that.
But we can we're also like, we do
it so, like, each each replica
depends on the previous one, so we get
a nice startup
behavior.
But this handles, like, also, like, recovery. So,
like, basically, you can scale down to one.
You can run a recovery,
like, when you break the cluster state and
stuff like that.
But you can see here, like, the args
here,
the design and recovery, and it equals the
bootstrap bootstrap indexes, which which one you wanna
bootstrap from.
Because when you're doing a recovery, you might
like, if if you screwed up your whole
cluster, then go, oh, crap. I wanna recover
and then bootstrap from, you know, the second
one, not the first one. So anyways. So
but, yeah, so there's all, you know, all
of all of that crap. So, like and
and this is like I haven't talked about
jobs at all, but you can do jobs
on a schedule. So it's like, this is
actually running a backup. This runs a a
backup of MariaDB and stores it into a
a volume.
But, yes, there's a lot of things in
here. If if you look at this read
me file for this, it
goes into more details on how to,
do all this stuff, like act active active
application.
Yeah. Removing replicas, whatever. Kind of all the
ops stuff you would need to know.
It's really cool. Like,
can it it keeps the backups, and it'll
show
it it actually has a list of the
backups that are available because there's some really
fancy things you can do because, like, there's
sorry. I'll I'll show you this. There's a
really cool secret type, which is just called
generated,
which you just run a job.
Let me go down here to secrets
templates.
Oh, crap. Where is it?
Nope. Nope. Nope.
I think it's in here.
Generated. Okay. Yeah. So there's a secret here,
which is called backup list, which is generated,
and it's off of the job called you
know, it runs off of the the backup
job. So what happens is when this this
job runs and it does the backup, the
output
of this
this script, there's a special
file you write to. It's like run secrets
output or something like that. In that job,
you write to that file, and then we
pick that up and throw it into the
secret. So this was, like, an interesting hack
of, like, when we run the backup,
the output of the backup
gets stored into the secret, and then you
can just list it. So, anyways, that was
a fun little hack that
Bill found. One of our engineers.
Right. Awesome.
Anyways yeah. So that was a very long
long approach to
Alright. We don't have any more questions in
the comment section right now. So before we
jump back, just to, like, quick face mode,
is there anything else you would like to
show us that you think is really cool
about Acorn?
Well, so I I was gonna show you
this, but, like, I think we're probably running
out about time, so I don't wanna go
go much further. But I'll just kinda point
you. So this was something, somebody had asked
me for a Jenkins,
to do,
what would it look like to run Jenkins
and Acorn.
And so I wanted to show this real
quickly. This is like, you can run this,
Acorn. So, basically,
build it, run this, and then you just
say expose the admin user, and that will
give you the password.
But in here, like, this is super,
cool. This is running j Jenkins,
and it's using the, configuration as code approach,
which integrates with Kubernetes. And it's also using
the Kubernetes, cloud plugin.
So it's pretty most of the stuff seems
pretty straightforward. Like, set up a bunch of
directories. These are ephemeral. These are coming from
secrets. This This is the file, and then
a bunch of probes.
Oh, the formatting. This is terrible.
But
so I just wanna show you. So this
is where you can actually request permissions. So
this is, like, a short syntax which just
says, like, basically, give me read, write access
to pods.
This is read only to pods log. This
is, like, the more verbose syntax, which will
give you you know, you can ask ask
for anything you want. So you can
get privileges.
And so that this uses it because this
internally is using the Kubernetes cloud thing. So,
like, when you run this, it's really cool,
little Acorn. Because, like, when you run it,
it comes up, and it's already wired up
to Kubernetes. So if you set up a
job, it's gonna launch a pod in Kubernetes
and, you know, start running the the Jenkins
jobs or whatever.
But I just wanted to show you, like,
the way that's controlled, like, kind of the
security. Because, like, when you ask for permissions,
as I was mentioning before, like, that is
kind of breaking the abstraction.
So it's very explicit of
let's see if oh, this might take
a little
bit. K. Won't tell long it'll take to
build this.
Because this is this internally is actually doing
a it has a custom a custom image
for the builder because I was trying to
get it to work for my own thing.
So the the image has, like, go in
it or something. So it has to do
that. But I don't think it should be
that that take that long. Let's let's see.
But I just because I just wanted to
show you the experience. Like, when you go
to run it, it's going to it's very
explicit of, like, this thing is asking for
permissions.
So you can't run something
without basically saying
saying if it asks for permissions, you have
to explicitly agree to letting it have permissions.
And then on top of that, you can't
give permissions you don't have, like, just regular
Kubernetes escalation checks, like that type of stuff.
It will it will do that. Okay.
Let's see. Wow.
GCC.
Oh, because I installed.
I'm just like, what in the world? I
thought I just well, I was just installing
curl.
It's like, need to compile it for curl.
So
do you see a future here where we're,
like Watching. Acorns are gonna be published to,
like, their effect hub, and people can just
say, I wanna deploy Jenkins or Postgres, and
the Acorns are publicly available and easily consumed.
Yeah. Yeah. And that's what we'd like to
get to because it's like Docker, you know,
Docker did a decent job of, like, you
know, creating shareable Docker images.
But,
honestly, like, the Helm chart ecosystem
of running apps, I mean, if anybody's, like,
realistically used a lot of the Helm charts
out there, you'll know that, like,
they basically will never run the first try.
And, you know, it takes quite a bit
to finally get the arguments right and eventually
figure out. And then it's, like, a lot
of reading and knowing what the best you
know? So it's like, I don't think the
ecosystem is very good in terms of, like,
you know, these applications and stuff like that.
What what you see right now is, like
if you look at, like, let's say, like,
hub, what's available for operator, the majority of
the things are all, like, Kubernetes infrastructure oriented.
You know? So, like, security scanners or
operators that you know? So it's, it's not
really
applicate you know? So it's, I don't know.
I'm I'm, and I'm in general, like, not
a big fan of operators. I don't think
that's, like, a very good pattern.
Like, I'm not saying don't use operators because
it's kinda, like, the best thing that exists
right now.
But
hope
to see that we can basically
create a stronger ecosystem around Acorns than what
Helm or operators has done.
Okay. So, finally, that took forever. So when
you go to run this, this is what
it's gonna do. It's gonna it's gonna warn
you. And so, like, this is very dangerous,
but it's saying, like, okay. This app is
requesting these scope like, these these permissions,
and then you have to agree to it.
But if I agree to it, then this
is basically
this is gonna bring up my my
this will bring up Jenkins.
Anyway so yeah. So that was probably, like,
the last thing I wanna show.
Awesome. I'm gonna pop this back over then
here.
Okay.
So that was really cool. If anyone has
any more questions before we finish up, now
is your time to drop them into the
comment section.
That end, I'll I'll kinda give you one
more for myself. But you said this project
is really young. It's really early. Things are
moving fast. Like, what's coming up? What's on
the road map for the next kinda couple
of months?
So just minor
so, like,
we're adding just, like, a bunch of, like,
little minor things, like, of so TLS support
is coming
so that, like, out of the box, we'll
just automatically wire up TLS. Again, certain manager
already works, but so that's coming.
You know, being able to label and annotate
everything because people wanna be able to put,
you know, different annotations that do weird things
under the hood in Kubernetes.
So, we're adding support to basically label and
annotate everything.
You know, the the language, as I said,
is, like, it's it's queue right now, but
we're trying to form like, it's a sub
it's kinda like a fork of queue right
now, but we're trying to formalize that into
our into our own things so it becomes
very clear, the scope of what we're using
and everything.
But the bigger stuff that's coming is
and, you know, let's see where we we're
almost in September. Right? Like, it's the August.
Yeah. So, like, of course, we're, like, conference
driven, so conference driven development. So we're shooting
for, like, cube con time.
We'll have a much bigger features in the
realm of kinda like CICD and stuff.
So, basically, once you have the Acorn, how
do you very quickly wire up the pipeline?
Right now, it already works very well. Like,
I didn't show this, but when you do
Acorn run, you can do dash o YAML,
and it will just basically spit out the
CRD,
and you can put that into your GitOps
flow. So it's like, if you're already doing
GitOps today, Acorn integrates super well into into
any GitOps flow.
But, like, we kinda believe the the entire
everything could be significantly easier. So how do
you do, like, automated builds and deployments and
and, CI?
Like, like, one of the one things that
we've we've already talked about this one. This
feature is, like, the idea of running, like,
Acorn test.
So the idea of Acorn test is, like,
within a CI flow, you wanna test your
application. So it's like with Acorn, it's very
easy to just spin up your application.
You know, you just do Acorn Run, and
you can run it anywhere. It's kind of
self contained or whatever. You can very easily
spin it up. So we wanna add basically
a test mode where we spin up the
application, but then you define a series of
jobs,
you know, and you can basically when you
you say test foo, it'll run the test
job, which can then do, like, an integration
test suite or or or whatever. And so
you can very easily test your application within,
a CI flow Okay. You know, to to
do, like, integration tests really easily.
Awesome.
No.
So those that's some of the stuff coming.
Well, it sounds exciting. And I've been called
out by Russell in the chat who asked
the question five minutes in. So eighty minutes
ago, and I didn't throw it to you.
So I'm gonna do that now. But Russell
wants to know what's actually in the OCI
image slash artifact. Oh.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So I can describe it.
So because if we get this the question
comes up a lot too because they're like,
oh, are you copying all the image? Like,
okay. So when we built the when we
build the Acorn image,
the top level like, I'll get into, like,
the OCI
details or whatever. Because, like, OCI has
basically manifest and
lists or index. I think it's called an
index.
So an index is a thing that just
points to a bunch of other things, and
then, the manifest,
describes basically like a like a a container,
a Docker image that has layer refers to
layers.
Okay. So,
when we build the Acorn image, we create
one layer which has the Acorn metadata in
it, and then we create a list which
links to the metadata
and then to all the existing Docker images
by digest.
And so if we built an image, like,
we'll build that, push that, and then link
it. If it's an image you just referenced
in your Acorn file, we just reference the
the same like, the exact same one. So
we don't duplicate any content. It's not a
new structure. So if you have an existing
Docker image, like the digest that's there, we
use that digest
directly.
The only thing is that, like,
the manifest list, if you're doing multi arc,
will will change because, like, we dereference to
find the architectures.
But, anyway, so, like, the the layers and
the content, like, those digest don't change.
There will when you use Acorn, you will
see if you push somewhere.
Like, if you didn't like, let's say you
just built an Acorn image and it just
has the metadata and it's referencing existing Docker
images. If you push it somewhere, you'll see
it's pushing tons of content. That has to
do with, like, more of, like, a bug
right now in the implementation
because the content already exists in the in
the registry,
but it doesn't necessarily exist in your repo.
So we're doing a push pushing content that
we don't need to push.
This is, like, there's a a feature in
in the API called mounting, and we're not
doing that properly in some scenarios.
So it looks like you're pushing a bunch
of content, but it's, like, basically, you push,
like, all the content, and then the registry
throws it away because it it already exists
there.
Anyways Alright.
Okay. So followed up with a question, which
I think you've just answered, which is that
do the images remain the same? Oh. Yeah.
Because then I think he says that you've
answered that, and then he says And then
there's a question about how does it handle
So for the interregistry
images okay. So this is really important. Is
that, like so what we're doing is, like,
is if you're pull if you're
when we push the Acorn, all the content
for that Acorn and all the reference docker
images go to that target one. So if
you've pulled from, like, five different registries, it's
going to pull all that content and push
it into your one registry.
That is very much done by design because,
like, the idea is once you have your
Acorn,
it's fully encapsulated.
So if anyone's done air gap setups, you'll
you'll understand the pain of this. Like, when
you do let's say you deploy a Helm
chart and you try to do an Helm
in a air gap, that Helm chart references
three Docker images. You have to configure each
one of those Docker images of, like, well,
what's the repo to pull from? You know,
where to get that? You're like, you have
to find all that content and and mirror
it offline.
So this basically just turns your app into
one artifact. And so it's like, you can
just basically do Acorn pull and then Acorn
push to a different registry, and that's it.
Or you you don't have to use Acorn.
You can use, like, a tool like Scorpio
or Crane
to do some of that stuff. Don't use
Docker because Docker mutates stuff as you push
and pull. But if you use a tool
like Scorpio or Crane, you can just move
things around.
Awesome.
Well, we've gone a little bit over time,
but we have no more questions. So I
just wanna say thank you for joining us
today, for sharing all of your knowledge and
the history behind Acorn and for walking us
through a couple of different demos and how
it works. I hope people are excited to
check it out. And definitely
reach out to Darwin with your feedback. I'm
sure he'd love to love to have.
Yeah. Yeah. And so I'm on I'm on
Twitter. I build the cloud on Twitter. I'm
pretty active there. If you have anything, just
ping me there. That's that's, like, the main
thing I usually check is Twitter.
Alright. Well, thank you again for your time.
Have a wonderful day, and I'll speak to
you again soon.
Have a good day.
Okay. Thanks.